[Music]
boots are a key staple during the fall
and winter seasons and stars like
kendall Jenner Rihanna and Selena Gomez
are nailing you know this year's trends
so we did some digging into their
Footwear I'm talking boot trend tape
price and brands we got it off and it's
just a really really great first up the
colored booties
check out gigi hadid on point with the
red trend she opted for a pair by Stuart
Weitzman that cost five hundred and
seventy five bucks you know fashion
should be fun and it's about finding new
ways of wearing things next Victoria
Beckham going with mint green Balenciaga
booties that retail for over a thousand
dollars and also you can move you can
feel comfortable Rihanna also went with
Balenciaga in a royal blue hue her
velour ones retail for seven hundred and
ninety five dollars now it's like guys
the limit no rules
next the white boot trend that you've
seen all over kendall Jenner tried out
in this pair by Stuart Weitzman they go
for 575 you kind of try and go for what
whatever is the most unique and
different well sister Kim Kardashian
stepped out in these they're part of the
easy season five collection and will
cost you just over seven hundred bucks I
want to wear things that make me feel
good about myself when it comes to thigh
high boots
Kerry Washington it was fierce and these
red kicks they go for around eight
hundred and eighty-five dollars
Haley Baldwin's more subtle and tan pair
also Stuart Weitzman are a little under
eight hundred bucks and Bella Hadid
tried the hot trend and forest green
this pair from Maria Kate fisherman sell
for four hundred and sixty eight bucks I
guess I'm doing something right but
leave it to Taylor Swift and Selena
Gomez to slay the classic black bootie
style Taylor went rocker chic and these
flat combat style buckle boots by Prada
worth a nine hundred and fifty bucks
whatever and Selena stepped out in this
healed hiking inspired boots by Stuart
Weitzman adjust under six hundred bucks
all right guys which celeb do you think
rocked the cutest boot trend of the very
best let me know over on Twitter and
I'll see you next time
[Music]
you